[Música]
daniela hablando nuevamente vamos a
hablar de economía pero si tuviéramos
vamos a jugar me gusta jugar si
tuviéramos toda esa plata cuánto pagaría
por el cuadro que más le gusta a usted
hay no la verdad es que yo no soy tan
amante del arte no pagaría ni un peso no
nada pues yo sí pagaría esos casi 200
millones de dólares por ese cuadro de
marín me acuerdo cuando era más chiquito
que no chiquita
quiero mi favorito danny pero hablemos
ahora nadie está mente
de la economía porque el mundo
empresarial ya empieza a ver las
consecuencias de esta guerra el
ucraniano sabe raúl es que estamos en
plena temporada de presentación de
resultados ante los accionistas por lo
menos de las empresas que cotizan en
bolsa y el periodo correspondiente al
primer trimestre de 2022 gran parte de
las compañías que abandonaron nos
suspendieron operaciones en rusia ya ha
visto reflejado este impacto en sus
libros de contabilidad le voy a mostrar
algunos ejemplos en el primer trimestre
reno dice que perdió unos 166 millones
de dólares debido a que rusia de su
segundo mercado más de después de
francia por su parte de la cervecera
belga ab inbev provisión o un cargo por
deterioro de 1100 millones de dólares
netflix sin darse infras adelantó que
perdió 700 mil suscriptores otros han
ido más allá pues de este primer
trimestre y han hecho proyecciones más
amplias heineken concluyó en marzo que
su negocio ya no era viable en rusia y
calcula el impacto total de su salida en
unos 400 millones de euros mcdonald's
por su parte también pierde unos 50
millones de dólares al mes por no operar
sus
847 locales en este país y el
estadounidense hasbro dejará de vender
unos 100 millones de dólares en juguetes
y mejor danny no sumemos todas esas
cifras porque pues son incalculables
vamos ahora a nuestra región nos venimos
a nuestra región vamos hablar de
petrobras porque subirá el precio del
diesel desde el martes lo anunció el
gigante estatal petrolero de brasil dice
que los precios del diésel tendrán su
segundo aumento en dos meses desde
4,51 reales por libra por litro a 4,91
esto es casi un dólar en que queda el
precio petrobras dijo que era necesario
para alinearse con los precios
internacionales del diésel a medida que
el suministro global de petróleo está
muy ajustado y no olvidemos que por este
motivo por la subida de los precios han
caído ya varios directivos de la empresa
por este motivo no le voy a decir porque
raúl porque más allá de lo polémico que
resulte elevar los precios la medida se
da menos de una semana después de que el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro instar a la
empresa a no volverlos a subir su
aumento esos argumentos que podría
provocar lo que llama una convulsión
nacional en efecto sólo en el primer
trimestre de este año esta firma obtuvo
ganancias netas de casi 9 mil millones
de dólares un valor 38 veces superior al
primer trimestre de 2021 cuando había
apenas había ganado unos 200 millones de
dólares y también es el mayor para un
trimestre en toda su historia
bolsonaro calificada esto de un crimen
inadmisible y ese ha sido uno de los
motivos que han llevado a bolsonaro a
promover la salida de los presidentes
por ejemplo yo aquí silva acaba de ser
reemplazado por josé mauro coelho por
las decisiones en torno a precios de
combustibles y su antecesor también
había salido por las mismas razones lo
delicado no que subir los precios de los
combustibles en un país danny y que la
producción de autos del mayor fabricante
del mundo se trata de china cuya venta
de automóviles en abril cayó en 35,7 por
ciento frente a hace un año en lo que
fue su mayor disminución desde marzo de
2020 el punto más álgido de la pandemia
el motivo principal fue el cierre de
fábricas en medio de la estrategia por
contener el rebrote del virus en
territorios como shanghai que cursa su
sexta semana de bloqueos justamente es
la que es el mayor fabricante de autos
de lujo del mundo detuvo también la
mayor parte de su producción en esta
ciudad dan indicadores económicos como
están la mayoría de los mercados
bursátiles asiáticos siguió los pasos de
wall street que en su jornada anterior
vio como algunos índices se desplomaban
en europa operan al alza las bolsas a
pesar de que la guerra la inflación el
aumento de tasas sigue sacudiendo a los
danny y nos quedamos en europa vamos
precisamente a pareja y ya está lista
nuestra periodista natal de ruiz con
toda la información de actualidad
francesa